dass der hp company presse zur meldung
an die frau bundesminister das ganze
recht
frau bundesminister obersten schmidt
meldet die militärmusik niederösterreich
die ehrenkompanie der garde der von der
harris und offiziere akademie sowie 4
654 wachtmeister drapierten kann weiter
ausbauen und drei somit eine miliz zum
festakt der aus mustang an geräten mit
dem festakt beginnen
[Musik]
das ganze 88 erik hoffmann schon
ja ich hab nie
dass der parade gut das ganze hat
ja ich hab an die presse fragt gerade
das ganze recht
[Musik]
das ganze parabel rupp
geschätzte ehren und festgäste
zuallererst ersuchen wir um ihr
verständnis für die ausrichtung des
rednerpults aufgrund der technischen
vorgaben waren wir gezwungen diese von
ihnen etwas abgewandte aufstellung zu
wählen
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
zuseherinnen und zuseher beim livestream
der kommandant der jahres und offiziers
akademie herr brigadier nikolaus ek wird
nun die begrüßung vornehmen und seine
ansprache halten
testen testen testen impfen impfen und
die frage wo ist der weg zurück zur
normalität
diese 654 damen und herren unsere
jüngsten unter offiziere des
österreichischen bundesheeres wurden in
den letzten 18 monaten getestet von
fachpersonal der gruppe im ersten teil
ihres ausbildungsabschnitte sie wollen
getestet von den spezialisten an den
waffen und fachschulen und sie wurden
auch auf herz und nieren getestet vom
methodisch geschulten personal der
harris und offiziers akademie und sie
wurden vom selben personal immer wieder
geimpft mit verschiedenen lernstufen die
sie auch zu lernen hatten und daher ist
der weg zur normalität für sie mit
montag bereits vorgegeben und gesichert
sie alle werden am montag bereits zur
truppe gehen und dort weg von der
bildungseinrichtung daher ist
unteroffizier akademie zur truppe gehen
und dort schon lange erwartet ihren
verantwortungsvollen dienst übernehmen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
sehr geschätzte 654 junge damen und
herrn wachtmeister des hausmeisters
jahrganges 2000 21 wir haben uns heute
zur mittlerweile gewohnt derzeit am
letzten freitag im februar aber an
ungewohntem ort innerhalb der kaserne
und in ungewohntem weil enorm
verkleinerten rahmen hier versammelt und
die feierliche übernahme der jüngsten
und offiziere des unter des bundesheeres
durch die truppe zu beginn dem grund der
leeren besucher ränge mit ausnahme der
ehrengäste wo ich mich sehr freue
des heutigen tages treffen allerdings
über die tatsache hinweg dass unsere
feier über livestream weltweit
übertragen wird und damit paradox
vermutlich sogar deutlich mehr menschen
das jetzige geschehen mitverfolgen
können als dies unter normalen
bedingungen der fall wäre eine sehr
geschätzten damen und herrn wachtmeister
wie wertvoll ihr abschluss und wir nun
anschließender dienst an der
gemeinschaft eingeschätzt wird das
zeigen ihnen rang und namen unserer
ehrengäste sich nun als akademiker land
stolz und mit freude begrüßen darf die
bereits sehr langer tradition wird
unsere ausmusterung durch die
anwesenheit der höchsten repräsentanten
unserer politischen führung geehrt
begrüße demnach mit besonderem stolz an
der spitze unserer fest und ehrengäste
ich sage es mit freude bereits zum
zweiten mal unsere frau bundesminister
magistra klaudia tanner
das land oberösterreich ist die
regionale heimat unserer
bildungseinrichtung die uns auch
emotional ganz besonders am herzen liegt
sehr herzlich darf ich auch bereits zum
wiederholten male den präsidenten des
oberösterreichischen landtages herrn
wolfgang stanek in unserer mitte
begrüßen
stellvertretend für die hohe
geistlichkeit und damit für alle
vertreter der glaubensgemeinschaften
dafür seine exzellenz unserer
militärbischof dr werner freistetter bei
uns herzlichst willkommen heißen
es ist uns eine besondere freude und
ehre zum ersten mal hier in enns den
wehrsprecher der evb und amtsführenden
vorsitzenden der parlamentarischen
bundesheerkommission abgeordneten zum
nationalrat friedrich ofenauer den
wehrsprecher der sp herrn abgeordneten
zum nationalrat robert ley sowie den wer
sprecher der grünen abgeordneten zum
nationalrat david stögmüller begrüßen zu
dürfen herzlich willkommen
als militärisch höchst anwesenden
begrüße ich respekt vor den
hochrangigsten offizier des
österreichischen bundesheeres chef des
generalstabs general magister robert
rieger
für die sektionsleiter im
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
begrüße ich den leiter der sektion 1
herrn sektionschef ministerialrat dr
eberhard hauser einen
kameradschaftlichen und respektvollen
willkommensgruß entbot ich dem stabschef
unserer frau bundesminister ein
generalmajor magister rudolf striedinger
stellvertretend für alle angehörigen der
personalvertretung und den
gewerkschaften darf ich den vorsitzenden
der bundesheergewerkschaft gewerkschaft
öffentlicher dienst und dritten
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden im
zentralausschuss war gestern weiterhin
willkommen heißen
es ist mir eine besondere freude der
bürgermeister unserer garnisonsstadt 1 1
franz stefan karlinger in unserer mitte
zu begrüßen
es gibt heute noch viel zu feiern
außerdem erwarten sie noch spannende
reden daher darf ich sie um ihr
geschätztes verständnis bitten wenn ich
nun abschließend wieder um möglichst
kurz zu bleiben alle vertreterinnen und
vertreter aus der politik den behörden
des militärs die insbesondere meine
kameraden aus dem kreistag akademie
unschuld kommandanten zu hause an den
bildschirmen alle familienangehörigen
und freunde unserer jüngsten
wachtmeister partner und
traditionsverbände ehemalige
kommandanten der akademie wirtschafts
und medienvertreter sowie
selbstverständlich alle bürgerinnen und
bürger die hier mit ihr interesse an der
veranstaltung zeigen ohne namentliche
erwähnungen ganz besonders herzlich
willkommen heißen
den abschliessenden gruß richtig noch an
die gäste die uns außerhalb österreichs
heute die ehre geben will come to all
our international guests
sie sind heute alle unsere ehrengäste
und haben sich jetzt den abschließenden
und vermutlich tausenden ablauf sehr
herzlich verdient
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
sehr verehrte fest und ehrengäste die
harris und offiziers akademie zeichnet
als bildungseinrichtung für die
allgemeine aus fort und weiterbildung
österreichischer und offiziere des
berufs und militantes verantwortlich
eine allgemeine und geschlossen
organisierte berufsausbildung zum
unteroffizier gibt es mittlerweile seit
einem vierteljahrhundert deren
einführung bildet der im jahr 1995 das
gründungsdatum der heute in akademie die
aus der vormaligen harris unteroffizier
schule hervorgegangen ist
nach pandemie bedingten absage eines
festaktes am 9 oktober des letzten
jahres zum jubiläum des 25 jährigen
bestehens und nach bereits erfolgter
herausgabe einer festschrift möchten wir
unseren akademie geburtstag heute auch
praktisch noch ein bisschen mitfeiern
erlauben sie mir nun in wenigen sätzen
zu erläutern in welchem kontext sich
jene ausbildung bewegt den abschluss wie
heute würden diese 2016 in kraft
befindliche kader anwärter ausbildung
steht das fundament der grundausbildung
zum unteroffizier tavernen den bergen
werden in den beiden ersten abschnitten
dieses ausbildungsganges noch künftige
offiziere und unteroffiziere gemeinsam
geschult so bildet der dritte teil
gewissermaßen das alleinstellungsmerkmal
für die qualifizierung von unter
offizieren
dieser beginnt für soldatinnen und
soldaten in der berufslaufbahn jedes
jahr am anfang september und endet mit
der ausmusterung zum wachtmeister sowie
am heutigen tag ende februar die karten
wörter ausbildung drei beendet die
ausbildung zur führungskraft auf der
ebene einer gruppe und legt den
grundstein
für eine künftige tätigkeit als
ausbildungsprofil mit besonderer
expertise im feld der
ausbildungsmethoden zudem werden in den
letzten wochen oder monaten der karte
anwärter ausbildung die einschlägige
dienstrechts ausbildung als
voraussetzung für eine übernahme als
militär berufsunteroffizier
abgeschlossen und die als nicht ohnedies
schon vorhandenen dafür notwendigen
allgemeinen und fachspezifischen
englisch kenntnisse vermittelt die
qualifikation einer militär berufs und
offizieren oder eines militär
berufsunteroffizier sin erst funktion
ist seit dezember 2018 den nationalen
qualifikationsrahmen auf der ebene 4
zugeordnet womit ich habe anwärter
ausbildung 1 bis 3 durch das
bildungsministerium de facto einer
vollwertigen berufsausbildung gleich
gestellt wurde
es sind heute auch wieder etliche nun
fertig ausgebildete miliz und offiziere
angetreten deren ausbildung aus
verschiedensten gründen zum teil
deutlich anders aufgebaut werden muss
diese kameradinnen und kameraden
besitzen für das österreichische
bundesheer und dessen
einsatzbereitschaft eine ganz enorme
bedeutung der freut mich als akademiker
land besonders so wie jedes jahr junge
und offiziere des berufs und des
mittelstandes wie auch in allen unseren
einsatzszenarien gemeinsam und feind
einer breiten öffentlichkeit
präsentieren zu dürfen
es ist mir an dieser stelle sehr wichtig
wieder einmal aus ganzem herzen dank zu
sagen mein dank gilt zunächst ihnen
allen die sich heute hier und zu hause
an den übertragungs geräten versammelt
haben um unsere jüngsten wachtmeister
beim übergang von selbst noch
auszubildenden zu ausbildern und
führungskräften persönlich zu begleiten
ich bedanke mich bei meinen vorgesetzten
und kooperationspartnern für die uns
stets zuteil werdende unterstützung bei
der erfüllung unseres auftrages
ein besonderes dankeschön richtig an
alle ausbildungsverantwortlichen stellen
für die karte anwärter ausbildung und
insbesondere an die waffen und
fachschulen für die bereits jahrelange
konstruktive zusammenarbeit bei der
erfüllung dieses gemeinsamen auftrag ein
ganz besonderer dank geht an die
landesverteidigungsakademie so werden
die theresianischen militärakademie und
deren kommandanten general leuten und
magister erich zivkovic sowie
generalmajor minister karl braun hg für
unsere kameradschaftliche und aus meiner
sicht äußerst gewinnbringende
kooperation im rahmen des wirkungs
verbundes der militär hochschule die
harris und offiziers akademie ist seit
deren gründung im jahr 2017 in diesem
wirkungs verbund integriert wir konnten
in den vergangenen etwas mehr als drei
jahren schon unter beweis stellen wie
viel kraft in der zusammenarbeit dreier
organisatorisch unabhängige aber bei
forschungs und entwicklungsaufgaben an
einem strang ziehenden akademien des
bundesheeres steckt teams haben wir uns
stets und konstruktive und kreative
ideen bemüht die vor einigen monaten an
uns vergangene aufforderung zu einer
nochmaligen vertiefung der
zusammenarbeit in diesem besagten
wirkungs verbund der militär hochschule
stellt für uns einerseits eine große
organisatorische herausforderung aber
andererseits auch einen besonderen
motivationsschub da mein allergrößter
dank jedoch um diesen kreis zu schließen
der gilt ihnen sehr geehrte damen und
herren wachtmeister die sie nun als
jüngste unteroffizier des bundesheeres
sichtlich und verdientermaßen stolz von
stehen
sie haben sich einer
umfangreichen langen und oft sehr
schwierigen ausbildung unterzogen und
sind nun in der lage eine verantwortung
für andere menschen zu übernehmen wie
sie in so jungen jahren in keinem
anderen beruf verlangt wird das militär
muss bereit sein im rahmen des
staatlichen krisenmanagements noch immer
antworten zu geben wenn alle anderen
bereits zum schweigen verurteilt sind
ich hoffe ich hoffte bislang immer
zutiefst alene hätten recht die uns
österreicher auf einer für immer
gesicherten insel des friedens und
wohlstands wänden allein die krise
selber angriffe auf strategische ziele
wie unsere außenministerium oder
wirtschaftsunternehmen und wenn
verheerender anschlag in wien haben uns
im vergangenen jahr sehr deutlich eines
besseren belehrt sicherheit bildet die
grundlage für unseren wohlstand
wir sollten diese mit allen verfügbaren
mitteln aufrechterhalten und fähig seien
sie wieder herzustellen wenn sie einmal
in schieflage geraten sein sollte
dazu benötigen wir als staat
funktionieren die einsatzkräfte mit gut
ausgebildeten personal und einer
effizienten ausrüstung dazu benötigen
wir ein einsatzfähiges ein
einsatzbereites österreichisches
bundesheer als letzte antwortmöglichkeit
auf szenarien die etwa unsere polizei
aufgrund ihres auftrages und ihrer
ausrüstung nicht mehr bewältigen kann
und von denen wir und unsere kinder aber
hoffentlich verschont bleiben unser herr
konnte und musste etwa seit beginn der
korona krise und damit für teile der
bevölkerung besonders gut sichtbar seine
einsatzbereitschaft und fähigkeit als
strategische reserve der republik unter
beweis stellen
das bundesheer benötigt ein starkes
rückgrat das vorrangig von ihnen
geschätzte damen und herren und
offiziere
das von ihnen gebildet wird und
schlussendlich dazu braucht unser und
offizierskorps nun gerade sie eine junge
kameraden als enorm wichtige verfügung
und verstärkung zur gleichen zeit sie
haben in den vergangenen monaten unter
erschwerten bedingungen sehr viel
gelernt
jetzt gilt es für sie das bisher
gelernte bestmöglich und abgestützt auf
weiteres lebensbegleitendes lernen in
professioneller weise wie gesagt ab
montag dann auch in der praxis
umzusetzen
meine junge kameraden bedenken sie dabei
immer im mittelpunkt steht der mensch
und behandeln sie alle ihnen
anvertrauten soldatinnen und soldaten
genauso wie auch sie behandelt werden
möchten
zum abschluss meiner ausführungen darf
ich sie meine damen und herren
wachtmeister nun wie alle ihre vorgänger
guten gewissens und in der hoffnung auf
ein wiedersehen im rahmen ihrer fort und
weiterbildung von der akademie
verabschieden denn ich weiß sie alle
sind bereit
geschätzte er in und festgäste der
folgenden programmpunkt ist der übergabe
des erinnerungs bandes zum 25 10 jahres
jubiläum der harris und offiziers
akademie gewidmet
hören sie dazu die ansprache des
präsidenten der österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft herrn 14 leuten
und roma wohl könig
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin sehr
geehrter herr präsident zum landtag
oberösterreich sehr geehrter herr
vorsitzender der parlamentarischen
bundesheerkommission und sehr geehrter
herr bär sprecher sehr geehrter herr
general hochgeschätzte generalität
kommandantin kommandanten sehr geehrter
herr bürgermeister
sehr geehrte herren festgäste liebe
damen und herren im livestream aber vor
allem sie sehr geehrte damen und herren
wachtmeister meine kameradinnen und
kameraden
es ist für mich ein berührender moment
zum letzten mal stehe ich hier und darf
der ausmusterung der wachtmeister meiner
und officers kameradinnen und kameraden
beiwohnen
vielen dank dass mir diese ehre zuteil
wird nochmals 10 an sehr geehrte ihren
und festgäste aber vor allem zu ihnen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
marktmeister sprechen zu dürfen
zumal ich sie gemeinsam mit einem mit
meinen heute hier anwesenden kommando
unter bis kameraden ein stück ihres
weges begleiten durfte die heeres und
office akademie und die stadt linz haben
mich mein ganzes berufsleben lang nicht
nur im rahmen meiner aus- fort- und
weiterbildungen sondern auch im regen
meinungs- und erfahrungsaustausch
begleitet nach mehr als 42 jähriger
dienstzeit ist es an der zeit danke zu
sagen
ich bedanke mich bei meiner heimat
städte der gesundheitsakademie für das
rüstzeug dass sie mir mitgegeben hat
hier wurden mir werte und normen und vor
allem fähigkeiten vermittelt die mir in
all meinen funktionen im in und ausland
sehr hilfreich waren gewachsen
allerdings bin ich zu hause bei meinem
heimatort verband dem damaligen jag
panzer porto lohn 4 wo wir erfahrene und
offiziere richtungsweisend zur seite
gestanden sind übrigens eine führungs
maßnahme von uns und offizieren die
nicht nur damals sondern auch heute noch
gültigkeit hat
ich bedanke mich bei allen und
derzeitigen angehörigen der harris und
office academy sowie bei den
bediensteten der overbergschule kaserne
für die jahrzehntelange und auf
kameradschaft basierende zusammenarbeit
vor allem danke ich dem engagierten
ausbildungs personal unserer
bildungseinrichtung sowie jeden
einzelnen der zahlreichen externen
ausbildungstour führenden stellen nicht
zuletzt den waffen und park schulen für
die sorgfältige ausbildung für uns und
offiziere denn mit ihrer arbeit tragen
sie wesentlich zur zukunft unseres
bundesheeres bei dieser gelegenheit darf
sich der heeres- und offiziers akademie
den partner der österreichischen und
offiziersgesellschaft nochmals sehr
herzlich zum 25 jährigen
bestandsjubiläum gratulieren
sehr geehrte damen und herren
wachtmeister sie haben sich wohl für den
abwechslungsreichsten und herausfordernd
und beruf im öffentlichen dienst
entschieden wir die österreichische
offiziersgesellschaft mit der neuen
landespräsidenten sowie die kommando-
und office jäger des österreichischen
bundesheeres gratulieren ihnen von
ganzem herzen zur beförderung zum
wachtmeister ein höherer dienstgrad ist
aber auch ein mehr an verantwortung
vergessen sie nie obwohl wir zum glück
in frieden leben dürfen wurden sie
unabhängig ihrer waffengattung oder
fachrichtung für den einsatz ausgebildet
daher brauchen gerade sie als und office
hier ein hohes maß an physischer und
psychischer leistungsfähigkeit bleiben
sie daher konsequent und bringen sie ihr
erworbenes wissen bleiben sie neugierig
und entwickeln sich ständig weiter gehen
sie ihren weg aber lassen sie sich nicht
gehen führen sie durch vorbild es ist
nicht die einfachste aber die einzige
und effizienteste art zu führen
ich selbst habe mich 1979 für den wohl
schönsten beruf entschieden meinen
schluss wurde von beginn an von und
offizieren meinen group
und zugs kommandanten beeinflusst daher
seien sie sich auch darüber bewusst
es liegt vor allem in den händen von uns
unter offizieren
ob und wie wir unseren kader nachwuchs
generieren
wir haben aber auch anteil fahrern mit
welcher meinung junge staatsbürgerinnen
und staatsbürger sich eventuell für den
blitz laufbahn entscheiden oder wieder
ins zivilleben zurückkehren
sehr geehrte herren und festgäste
geschätzte kameradinnen und kameraden
als überzeugter berufs und ob es hier
mache ich mir selbstverständlich
gedanken über die zukunft unseres
bundesheeres und natürlich ergeben sich
stark auf wünsche so wünsche ich mir für
unser bundesheer dass der derzeitige und
auch in der öffentlichkeit spürbare
aufwärtstrend nachhaltig genutzt wird
und dass in den kommenden wochen die
weichen richtig gestellt werden
vor allem aber dass sich unser
bundesheer sobald ist die kogit lage
wieder zulässt ausgerichtet auf die
militärische landesverteidigung sich in
seinem kern fähigkeiten wieder
weiterentwickeln darf nahezu 15 jahren
durfte ich am höhepunkt meiner laufbahn
die verantwortungsvolle und
herausfordernde funktion des kommando
und offiziers ausüben
ich tat dies nach besten wissen und
gewissen und mit demut zumal ich mir der
großen verantwortung und der tragweite
dieser aufgabe bewusst war
hier knüpft mein wunsch für uns und
offizieren
ich wünsche mir dass der prozess der
weiteren implementierung der kommando
und offiziere dynamisch fortgesetzt wird
denn dadurch kann mit einem geringen
finanziellen mehraufwand ein wertvoller
beitrag zur stärkung der fähigkeiten von
uns und offizieren und somit der
höchster des österreichischen
bundesheeres erreicht werden
abschließend darf ich mich ganz
persönlich beim kommandanten der heeres
unter business akademie für die ziel und
ergebnisorientierte zusammenarbeit sowie
für unsere bestehende partnerschaft und
vor allem kameradschaft st
für die zukunft wünsche ich der herr ist
und ob es hier sagt hat ihm alles gute
und vor allem bremse ihrem leitspruch
wir prägen das bundesheer der zukunft
treu
sehr geehrte ehren und festgäste werte
kameradinnen und kameraden ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen allen für die vielen
schönen momente die ich in ihrem kreise
verbringen durfte ich wünsche ihnen
alles gute für die zukunft viele
soldaten glück und bleiben sie gesund
sehr geehrte damen und herren
wachtmeister getreu unseres buches seien
sie sich ihrer stelle und bewussten und
kräuter pflicht aber bleiben sie vor
allem wachsam und gerüstet es lebe die
heeres und office akademie das
österreichische und offizierskorps und
unser bundesheer
die nun folgende segnung des erinnerungs
bandes wird eingeleitet durch einen
choral dargeboten von der militärmusik
niederösterreich
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
versuche jetzt die vertreter der
katholischen der evangelischen der
orthodoxen und der muslimische seelsorge
die segnung des erinnerungs bandes
vorzunehmen
lesung aus dem brief an die philipper
wenn es ermahnung in christus gibt
zuspruch aus liebe eine gemeinschaft des
geistes herzliche zuneigung und erbarmen
dann macht meine freude dadurch
vollkommen dass ihr eines sinnes seit
ein anderer in liebe verbunden einmütig
und einträchtig dass ihr nichts aus
ehrgeiz und nichts als prahlerei tod
sondern in demut schätze einer den
anderen höher ein als sich selbst
jeder achte nicht nur auf das eigene
wohl sondern auch auf das der anderen
lasst uns beten gott zu ursprung aller
gemeinschaft segne dieses fahnenband und
schließe alle die diesem zeichenfolgen
zu einer gemeinschaft des friedens der
hilfsbereitschaft der solidarität
zusammen
darum bieten wir durch christus unseren
herrn
amen
im namen des vaters und des sohnes und
des heiligen geistes
herr segne dieses erinnerungsband der
harrah's unter fischers akademie liebe
absolventinnen und absolventen des
jahres
der herr ist unteroffizier akademie
liebe bergmann ist da möge gott der herr
euren frieden stiften dienst in unserem
österreichischen bundesheer segnen
der vater der sohn und der heilige geist
haben
ich beginne im namen gottes des albaners
des barmherzigen ich wollte heute ein
bittgebet bezug situation der welt
auszusprechen
oh allah befreie unsere welt von
aktuelle ansteckende krankheit
du hast die kraft beschütze uns vor alle
krankheiten und gibt uns kraft dass wir
uns das bewältigen können
in diesem sinne bitte ich den
allmächtigen gott für die gesamte
menschheit der welt möge sein heil und
segen ausbreiten
wenn der herr hess und doziert akademie
vertreten
sie erklärte festgäste ich versuche nun
frau bundesministerin magistra klaudia
tanner um die übergabe des erinnerungs
bandes als beigabe zur fahne harris und
offiziers akademie
sehr geehrte ehrengäste erlauben sie mir
ihnen einige informationen zur gestalt
des erinnerungs bandes zu geben dass
erinnerungsband ist doppelseite
gestaltet und schließt mit gold franzen
ab auf der vorderseite befinden sich auf
rot weißer und dem grund dass bekannt
farbige gestaltete warten der heeres-
und offiziers akademie für österreich
auf der befestigungs hätte oben in weiß
geschickter schrift jahresumsatz
akademie mittig auf weißem grund das
logo der burg und den hinweis
geschickter schrift 25 jahre burg auf
der rückseite befindet sich befestigung
seit ich das wappen des österreichischen
bundesheeres oben in weiß gestickt der
schrift bundesministerium für
landesverteidigung mittig auf weißem
grund das logo der burg unten in weiß
geschickter schrift das datum der
umstrukturierung der us zur burg der
zweite oktober 1955
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
übergabe des erinnerungs bandes wird
musikalisch durch den hessen magisch
abgerundet
[Musik]
das herz parade
sehr geschätzte damen und herren liebe
zuseherinnen und zuseher beim livestream
der festakt setzt nun mit der
ausmusterung ssf ehrlichkeit fort sie
hören jetzt die grußworte der stadt ins
durch den herrn bürgermeister franz
stefan karlinger
sehr geschätzte frau bundesministerin
magistra klaudia tanner
sehr geehrter herr general hohe
geistlichkeit geschätzte abgeordnete zum
österreichischen nationalrat sehr
geschätzter herr präsident des
oberösterreichischen landtag ist sehr
geehrter kommandant brigadier nikolaus
egger sehr geschätzte ehrengäste aber
insbesondere meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wachtmeister ich möchte mich
sehr herzlich für die einladung zur
ausmusterung der wester und den heutigen
tag bedanken
es ist mir immer wieder eine freude und
ehre an dem festlichen akt als vertreter
der stadt teilnehmen zu können und bin
stolz dass so viele neue und fürsorge im
schönen historischen ambiente der
ältesten stadt österreichs die
ausbildung genossen haben
ich bin immer sehr gerne und mit großem
respekt und besonderer wertschätzung
dieser einladung gefolgt ist doch die
heeres unter 40 akademie für die stadt
ins seit jeher auch damals aus hass und
offiziersschule von großer bedeutung
sie leistet nämlich einen wesentlichen
beitrag dazu dass unsere geliebte
heimatstadt weit über die landesgrenzen
hinaus bekannt ist
einerseits stellt sie einen
unverzichtbaren wirtschaftsfaktor dar
andererseits ist sie ein wertvoller und
fixer wesentlicher bestandteil unserer
tradition und geschichte und
gleichzeitig eine besonders bedeutet
volle ausbildungsstätte erfolgreicher
fach und führungskräfte des
österreichischen bundesheeres
die stadtgemeinde ins und ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger haben nicht nur
pandemie bedingt durch die
unterstützungsleistungen des
bundesheeres sondern schon immer ein
enges von gegenseitiger wertschätzung
geprägtes verhältnis zur harris und
offiziers akademie was seit jahrzehnten
in einem partnerschaftsvertrag
dokumentiert ist
in dieser partnerschaft städte
verbundenheit nicht nur ein paar bier im
gegenteil sie wird auch wenn es momentan
coroner bedingte einschränkungen gibt
gelebt neben gemeinsamen veranstaltungen
die die beziehung stärken ist es auch
die verlässliche und unverzichtbare
hilfe bei notsituationen die des staates
dance mit ihren menschen sehr zu
schätzen weiß und somit ist seitens der
installieren denn so eine sehr große
befürwortung und akzeptanz gegenüber dem
bundesheer entstanden die auch in zeiten
aufrecht bleibt in denen die
aufgabenstellung der landesverteidigung
von verschiedenen seiten immer wieder
durchleuchtet wird das gute miteinander
bestätigt mich darin dass der
eingeschlagene weg der richtige ist und
auch dieser fortzusetzen ist und somit
hat unsere partnerschaft nicht nur eine
erfolgreiche vergangenheit auf sie und
davon bin ich überzeugt wartet auch noch
eine viel versprechende zukunft eine
sehr geschätzten damen und herren es
wurde hat heute bereits erwähnt das
aufgabengebiet des bundesheeres hat sich
verändert
es ist nicht einfach im gegenteil es ist
grösser komplexer herausfordernder und
schwieriger geworden
die soldatinnen und soldaten stehen
heute mit ihren ganzen einsatz für
friedenserhaltende und humanitäre
einsätze und wir haben zwei starke
partner gegen die bedrohungen der
zukunft an unserer seite
sie geben uns sicherheit nicht nur im
katastrophen beispielgebend sind aber
dabei dürfen wir niemals vergessen dass
dies nicht selbstverständlich ist und
der steten arbeit für den frieden ist es
besonders wichtig dass es menschen wie
sie gibt dass es menschen gibt die mit
mut entschlossenheit aber auch
menschlichkeit mit gutem beispiel voran
gehen sie sehr geschätzt damen und
herren marktmeister haben sich alle der
verdienten ausbildung zum unteroffizier
unterzogen und damit genau entschieden
für sich selbst entschieden genau das zu
tun
mit der ernennung zum wagnis da haben
sie den ersten meilenstein in ihrer
laufbahn als unter fürs hier bewältigt
ihnen kommt zukünftig eine
schlüsselrolle bei der ausbildung der
gruppen zu und sie übernehmen damit auch
eine sehr große verantwortung
ich möchte ihnen für ihren einsatz und
für ihre gewählte berufliche aufgabe
meine anerkennung meinen respekt und ein
aufrichtiges dankeschön aussprechen und
ich wünsche ihnen namens der stadt ins
für ihren weiteren lebensweg und ihre
zukünftige soldaten laufbahn alles gute
und viel erfolg bei der erfüllung ihrer
aufgaben im dienste unserer republik
österreich
vielen dank und alles gute
sehr geehrte festgäste im anschluss
würden sie die grußworte des landes
oberösterreich
es spricht der präsident des
oberösterreichischen landtages herr
wolfgang stark daran anschließend folgt
der marsch der und offiziersgesellschaft
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin sehr
geehrte ehren und festgäste sehr geehrte
damen und herren wachtmeister meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
eigentlich hätte das jahr 2020 aus
demokratiepolitischer sicht ein jahr
großer feierlichkeiten sein sollen
100 jahre bundesverfassung 75 jahre
frieden 65 jahre staatsvertrag und damit
freiheit 25 jahre beitritt österreichs
zur europäischen union
aufgrund der pandemie konnten viele
feierlichkeiten nicht stattfinden auf
der unter bahn.de me ist das jahr 2020
für uns alle
trotzdem zu einem besonderen jahr
geworden
zu einem besonders herausfordernden jahr
wir alle haben mitbekommen wie viele
herausfordernde situationen sich in den
verschiedensten gesellschaftlichen
bereichen ergeben haben
manch einer wird sich wahrscheinlich
auch gedacht haben gibt es eigentlich
irgendeinen vorteil durch diese pandemie
wenn man darüber nachdenkt könnte man
sagen vielleicht ist es einer der
vorteile das vielen menschen durchaus
auch einmal bewusst geworden ist dass
nicht alles so selbstverständlich ist
wie das vortag pandemie mehr oder
weniger angenommen wurde
viele dinge in unserem leben sind
tatsächlich nicht selbstverständlich es
ist nicht selbstverständlich in einer
demokratie leben zu dürfen
es ist nicht selbstverständlich in
frieden und freiheit leben zu dürfen
dazu muss vieles getan werden
von verschiedenen organisationen ganz
besonders aber auch von jenen männern
und frauen die für die sicherheit in
einem lande ganz besondere verantwortung
tragen
sie tragen diese verantwortung aufgrund
ihrer dienstfähigkeit im bundesheer auf
grund ihrer ausbildung und dafür darf
ich ihnen auch im namen unseres
landeshauptmanns thomas stelzer ganz
besonders danken
sie haben an so hug eine
hochqualifizierte ausbildung absolviert
eine ausbildung im militärischen bereich
aber auch eine ausbildung im
persönlichkeitsbildenden bereichen eine
ausbildung in politischer bildung eine
ausbildung vor allem um junge menschen
in einer besonderen phase ihres lebens
qualifiziert begleiten und leiten zu
können
damit übernehmen sie auch eine hohe
verantwortung für das politische und für
das demokratische bewusstsein in unserem
lande
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
wenn sie heute an der hak sozusagen
ausmustern
dann ist das wiederum ein punkt wo man
sagen kann ich habe eine ausbildung
abgeschlossen aber jeder abschluss
bedeutet auch wiederum einen neubeginn
einen neubeginn in die richtung dass wir
uns gerade in qualifizierten berufen
immer weiterbilden müssen weitere
fortbildungen auf sie zukommen werden
und weitere große herausforderungen auf
sie zukommen werden
dafür wünsche ich ihnen von herzen alles
gute und ich wünsche ihnen vor allem
drei dinge
ich wünsche ihnen viel freude bei ihrer
arbeit weil ich zutiefst davon überzeugt
bin dass aus der freude auch
entsprechende energie entsteht
und weil ich weiters davon überzeugt bin
dass sie mit freude wenn sie mit freude
und mit energie an ihre aufgaben heran
gehen ihre aufgaben und
herausforderungen auch erfolgreich
meistern werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren es
ist mir auch noch ein großes anliegen
sondern auch ein wahrer leuchtturm des
österreichischen bundesheers in
verbindung mit der zivilbevölkerung und
dafür möchte ich mich bei ihnen
persönlich aber auch namens unteres
landeshauptmanns ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken und liebe frau bundesministerin
ganz zuletzt auch noch zu dir
ich bedanke mich bei dir ganz ganz
herzlich für die tolle zusammenarbeit
mit dem land oberösterreich ich bedanke
mich vor allem aber auch bei dir für
deine zu sagen gerade auch in
oberösterreich das bundesheer besonders
zu unterstützen weil es für uns in
oberösterreich ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass wir auf die kompetenz des
bundesheer sind in verschiedensten
bereichen zurückgreifen können
in diesem sinne meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wünsche ich ihnen allen
für die zukunft alles gute
bleiben sie bitte gesund
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ist er
folgt nun stellvertretend für alle
absolventen die beförderung der fünf
lehrgang sprecher der frauenbeauftragten
sowie des vertreters der beliebte und
offiziere an den lehrgangs besten des
lehrgangs gendarmerie schule
oberösterreich 2 wird das ehrengeschenk
der goldene ring der heeres- und
offiziers akademie überreicht herr
wachtmeister jonas kg hat bei den dienst
prüfungen neun von zehn möglichen
auszeichnungen erreicht er wird dienst
bei der der kompanie des
panzerbataillons vier versehen
hören sie im anschluss an die ehrungen
die ansprache des lehrgangs besten
gefolgt vom alt starren bergmann
ich versuche nun frau bundesministerin
magistra klaudia tanner
die begleitung von herrn wolfgang stanek
gern general magister robert peuker und
herren brigadier nikolaus die ehrungen
und beförderungen vorzunehmen
sehr geehrte ehren und festgäste
erlauben sie mir eine informationen über
den jahrgangs namen weiterzugeben
die damen und herrn wachtmeister
absolventen der vierten karton wird
ausbildung drei führenden lehrgangs
namen statt der marienschule
oberösterreich 2 diese bildete im
verbund der standard marie grundschulen
zwischen 1952 und 1955 die basis für
eine neue kommende armee die gendarmerie
schule oberösterreich zwei entwickelte
sich in weiterer folge zur kaderschmiede
des panzergrenadierbataillons 13 in
oberösterreich durch den willen der
beteiligten zum wieder erstehen eines
neuen staates österreich und unter
inkaufnahme von entbehrungen und
anstrengungen verdienen es die damals
handelnden personen auch in der jetzt
zeit als vorbilder für unser und und
offizierskorps zu dienen
apropos eintritt
wer kämpft kann verlieren wer nicht
kämpft hat schon verloren
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister sehr
geehrte damen und herren werte kameraden
wir stehen heute hier versammelt aus
allen teilen der republik mit
unterschiedlichen waffengattungen und
unterschiedlichen vorgeschichten eines
jedoch vereint uns die er nach der
entscheidung der republik österreich als
um dort die tiere treu zu dienen
diese entscheidung dieser weg den wir
eingeschlagen haben war nicht immer
einfach
wir haben jegliche herausforderung
gemeistert durchgehalten unser können
unter beweis gestellt und kameradschaft
gelebt doch genau das macht einen
soldaten und vor allem an herunter die
tiere aus denn unsere leistung beginnt
dort wo andere nicht mehr können wir
stehen stets bereit wenn man uns braucht
wir stehen stets bereit um unser land
und unsere mitmenschen zu verteidigen
all jenes das über die letzten jahre
gelernt und erreicht haben kann uns
niemand mehr nehmen
doch unser auftrag unsere aufgabe ist
noch nicht vollendet
viel wissen bedeutet auch viel
verantwortung mit dem dienstgrad geht
die verpflichtung einher
das erlernte vor zu machen um mit voller
überzeugung vorzuleben
nur dann wird es möglich sein gemeinsam
eine bessere zukunft zu schmieden
ich danke jene die uns auf diesem weg
begleitet und unterstützt haben
lang lebe das österreichische bundesheer
lang lebe die republik österreich
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren werte
zuseher beim live stream hören sie nun
die ansprache des militärisch höchst ein
bisschen den herrn general magister
robert peuker
dieser folgt das musikstück podium in
österreich
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister hohe
festversammlung sehr geehrte damen und
herren wachtmeister es ist ein großer
erfolg des bundesheeres das heute 654
junge berufs und beliebt unter offiziere
zu ihrer ausmusterung für uns angetreten
sind
diese große anzahl ist ein würdiger und
willkommener anlass zu einem festakt
wozu ich die frischgebackenen damen und
herren wachtmeister die geistlichen
vertreter und jene der zivilgesellschaft
sowie die militärischen abordnungen
recht herzlich willkommen heißen
der heutige tag ist somit auch ein
starkes zeichen für die bereitschaft zum
aufbruch zu neuen aufgaben
ich bin froh dass wir heute diesen
besonderen tag begehen können und sei es
auch unter speziellen auflagen leider
ohne ihre familien und angehörigen es
freut uns dass sie all die zahlreichen
anstrengungen und entbehrungen der
vergangenen kader anwärter ausbildung
erfolgreich gemeistert haben
ich darf jeden einzelnen von ihnen recht
herzlich zu diesem erfolg gratulieren
meine anerkennung gilt aber auch der für
ihre ausbildung verantwortlichen heeres
unteroffiziers akademie und den
durchführenden drucken körper
schließlich wollen wir heute auch der
tatsache gedenken dass es dem
kommandanten wie ihren mitarbeitern zu
verdanken ist dass es im verlauf der
letzten 25 oder eigentlich schon 26
jahre letztendlich gelungen ist die
ausbildung zum unteroffizier auch außer
militärisch anzuerkennen und den
berufsstand ist und offiziers in unserer
gesellschaft zudem zu erheben was er in
den augen des bundesheeres seit anbeginn
war die stütze und der eigentliche kern
der armee meine damen und herren
wachtmeister sie haben sich als
jahrgangs namen ihres ausrüsters
jahrgang ist an der marienschule
oberösterreich zwei erwählt und mir
scheint diese wahl in der heutigen zeit
besonders treffend man es doch die
angehörigen der b schon damals neu
geschaffene exekutiv körper der 2
republik neben der bundespolizei und als
ehemalige kriegsteilnehmer dieses
bundesheer in eine neue ära geführt und
es in seinen anfängen durch einsatz nahe
ausbildung strenge und korrektes
auftreten über viele jahre nachhaltig
und positiv geprägt haben
ich denke dass man in einigen jahren
über sie als vertreter der heutigen
jungen unteroffiziers generation ähnlich
urteilen wird das jetzt ihre aufgabe
sein wird unseren soldaten und die
herausforderungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zu führen wie sie wissen
befindet sich das österreichische
bundesheer in einer phase der
neuorientierung die als ziel die
bewältigung der zukünftigen
herausforderungen hat denken sie aber
nicht das neue bedrohungen nun die alten
ablösen und bisherige aufgaben durch
neue hinfällig werden
im gegenteil so wie schon daher
bürgermeister ausgeführt hat das
aufgabenspektrum unseres heeres
erweitert sich erheblich durch
neuaufträge jedoch die herkömmlichen
aufgaben der landesverteidigung bleiben
unverändert erhalten
dies bedeutet auch dass ihn als jungen
und offizieren sowie uns allen noch mehr
abverlangt wird als bisher
die gesellschaft erwartet von ihnen
höhere flexibilität und organisations
gabe mehr bereitschaft mitten in der
öffentlichkeit stehen für die
bevölkerung dazu seien dabei aber und
daran ist mir besonders wichtig zu
erinnern behalten die alten
militärischen tugenden unverändert ihre
bedeutung pflicht drei auftrags
erfüllung großes fachwissen beherrschung
des militärischen handwerks loyalität
ihren vorgesetzten sowie respekt und
fürsorge ihren untergebenen gegenüber
soll noch weiterhin die leitlinien ihres
dienstleistung sein das fordere ich von
ihm an und das erwartet auch die
bevölkerung von ihnen hierzu wird es
auch notwendig sein über ihren
unermüdlichen täglichen einsatz hinweg
sich durch lebenslange fort und
weiterbildung weiter zu entwickeln
das bundesheer insgesamt und hier
im speziellen die unteroffiziers
akademie als die heimat des
unteroffiziers standes bietet ihnen wie
kaum ein anderer arbeitgeber die chance
weiter zu lernen und so ihren
individuellen karriere weg zu
beschreiten
meine damen und herren wachtmeister mit
dem heutigen tag wechseln sie vom
schüler zum kommandanten zum ausbilder
und erzieher die republik österreich
vertraut ihnen ab sofort einen teil
ihrer jugend an diese herausragende
verantwortung für unsere soldaten findet
ihren ausdruck in der fürsorge und in
einem besonders sorgsamen und
respektvollen umgang ihr
pflichtbewusstsein und ihr vorbildliches
auftreten ihre soziale kompetenz
disziplin kameradschaft und körperliche
leistungsfähigkeit werden sowohl von
ihren untergebenen als auch von ihren
vorgesetzten mit besonderer
aufmerksamkeit verfolgt werden
in meiner verantwortung als
generalstabschef stelle ich fest dass
mit ihrem dienstantritt als best
ausgebildete junge kadersoldaten die
einsatzbereitschaft des bundesheeres
entscheidend gestärkt wird
die aufgabe der öffentlichkeit wird
jetzt darin liegen immer noch
entsprechende rahmenbedingungen und die
beste ausrüstung zur verfügung zu
stellen denn darauf haben sie einen
anspruch sind sie sich bewusst als sie
es unter offizieren
das rückgrat der armee darstellen ich
wünsche ihnen für ihre laufbahn als
unteroffizier des österreichischen
bundesheeres bei einigen aufgaben sowohl
in der präsenz organisation als auch in
der miliz persönliche erfüllung
gesundheit und viel soldatenglück es
lebe das österreichische bundesheer ist
lebe die republik österreich
[Musik]
hoch geschätzten und festgäste ich
versuche jetzt die frau bundesministerin
für landesverteidigung magistra klaudia
tanner um ihre ansprache
sehr geehrte militärbischof hohe
geistlichkeit sehr geehrter herr
landtagspräsident flecker daher auch
gerne offener herab geheimer stögmüller
sehr geehrter herr generalstabschef sehr
geehrter herr miliz beauftragter sehr
geehrter herr akademie kommandant sehr
geehrter herr präsident
darunter offiziersgesellschaft sehr
geehrter herr bürgermeister
sehr geehrte ehrengäste sehr geehrte
medienvertreter damen und herren die
auch via live stream heute mit dabei
sind sehr geehrte damen und herren
offiziere unteroffiziere chancen unsere
guten aber ganz besonders sehr geehrte
damen und herren wachtmeister hatte ist
ein großer tag heute ist ein großer tag
für sie
heute ist ein großer tag für uns alle
es ist ein großer tag obwohl es für sie
sicher nicht angenehm ist solange
während des festaktes unter reden hier
zu stehen in der einteilung
stillzustehen
es ist ein großer tag auch wenn es wegen
der korona maßnahmen zu großen
einschränkungen bei den feierlichkeiten
gekommen ist und es ist ein großer tag
obwohl bei manchen von ihnen vielleicht
ihre gedanken auch ganz woanders sind
zum beispiel dann wenn ein
familienangehöriger krank geworden ist
doch ist es ist ein ganz großer tag für
sie weil die beförderung zum
wachtmeister ein bedeutender schritt in
ihrer karriere
weil sie erfolgreich die ausbildung zum
unteroffizier abgeschlossen haben und es
ist ein großer tag für uns alle weil
weitere 654 soldatinnen und soldaten als
wachtmeister zum österreichischen
bundesheer ausmustern und gemeinsam mit
den anderen männern und frauen des und
offiziers costa als rückgrat der armee
bilden und die offiziere
sind also das rückgrat der armee diese
feststellung wurde und wird nicht nur in
österreich sondern auch in vielen
anderen armeen getroffen und das mit
recht
das allein schon aktuell die seit einem
jahr laufenden vielseitigen corona
einsätze gezeigt und die tatsache wie
gut unsere unteroffiziere übrigen
einsätze im in- und im ausland und vor
allem auch die ausbildung der
grundwehrdiener unter erschwerten
bedingungen wegen der einschränkenden
notwendigen maßnahmen gemeistert haben
sie sind die stützen im täglichen
dienstbetrieb bei ausbildungen übungen
bei den nationalen und internationalen
einsätzen des österreichischen
bundesheeres sie versehen ihren dienst
als fach unter offiziere in allen
waffengattungen und stäben
doch bevor es soweit ist erhalten sie
die dementsprechende ausbildung unter
der verantwortung der heeres- und
offiziers akademie und es freut mich
dass wir heute trotz corona 613 männer
und 41 frauen als neue unter offizieren
im bundesheer willkommen heißen können
und ich freue mich auch dass 301
angehörige der miliz darunter auch eine
frau in ihren reihen stehen die work
existiert als wichtige ausbildungsstätte
bereits seit mittlerweile 63 jahren im
jahre 1995 wurde sie zur akademie
aufgewertet ja und leider herr
kommandant ist im vorjahr die feier zum
25-jährigen jubiläum der korona pandemie
zum opfer gefallen daher hat es mich
wirklich gefreut dass wir das jubiläum
würdigen konnten mit dem eigenen
programmpunkt der segnung des
erinnerungs bandes die ausbildung
unserer soldaten sehr geehrte damen und
herren und seit 998 soldatinnen zu
führungskräften an diese
ausbildungsstätte hat eine lange
tradition ja und die uhr bleibt auch in
weiterer folge die heimat der
unteroffiziere nicht nur dann wenn es um
die fort und weiterbildung von unter
offizieren des berufs und militant es
geht wenn manche von ihnen kehren ja
auch aus ausbildner wieder an die eigene
ausbildungsstätte zurück und darüber
hinaus ist die akademie ja auch die
kompetente einrichtung für alle fragen
der entwicklung des österreichischen und
offizierskorps soldatinnen und soldaten
sie haben monatelang ihre ausbildung zur
führungskraft absolviert und tragen
jetzt den dienstgrad wachtmeister sie
sind von nun an ein bindeglied ein
bindeglied zwischen den offizieren und
den mannschaften
sie arbeiten als kommandant ausbilder
und erzieher oder als fach unteroffizier
in einer kompanie oder sie gehen
möglicherweise als wachtmeister der
miliz in den auslandseinsatz
aber egal wo sie zum einsatz kommen von
ihnen geht engagement flexibilität
mobilität und professionalität gefordert
bei der arbeit im inland genauso wie in
auslandseinsätzen seien sie ein vorbild
sein sie ein vorbild für andere sein sie
es besonders dann wenn sie mit grund
wird ihnen zu tun haben sie dürfen nicht
vergessen die grundwehrdiener werden das
bundesheer in erster linie über sie
wahrnehmen und erleben sie werden
mitunter die wichtigste dienstliche
bezugsperson für die jungen männer und
frauen im grundwehrdienst und im
ausbildungsdienst sein
die grundwehrdiener sie sind die basis
sind die basis unseres bundesheeres ohne
sie gibt es keine karte soldaten ohne
grundwehrdiener gibt es keine miliz
bitte halten sie auch weiterhin während
der korona pandemie durch seien sie auch
weiterhin durch die einhaltung der
maßnahmen in den einsätzen und bei der
ausbildung der grundwehrdiener ein
verantwortungsvolles vorbild ihr einsatz
für das bundesheer ist gerade jetzt in
schwierigen zeiten wichtig sowohl bei
den vielen zusätzlichen einsätzen die
durch die pandemie entstanden sind aber
auch bei den norm aufgaben die ja
trotzdem erfüllt werden müssen
gerade bei der ausbildung der
grundwehrdiener spielen sie eine äußerst
wichtige rolle
auf der anderen seite kann ich ihnen
aber auch versichern
es geht mit dem bundes jahr als ganzes
wieder bergauf wir haben mehr budget wir
haben sonder finanzierungspaket wie nie
zuvor wir haben eine reihe von
investitionen die wir tätigen müssen um
mannes ausrüstung waffen und gerät die
mobilität zu stärken und zu verbessern
wir müssen investieren in die
infrastruktur der kasernen in ganz
österreich generalsanierungen und
ausbauten vieles muss auf vordermann
gebracht werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren unter
offizieren
ich bedanke mich ich bedanke mich für
ihre einsatzbereitschaft ich bedanke
mich dafür dass sie unsere heimat
schützen das österreichische bundesheer
dass es dafür unsere sicherheitsgarantie
sie selbst sie sind ein wichtiger teil
davon sehr geehrte damen und herren
wachtmeister sie mussten jetzt zu ihren
verbänden aus und werden diese mit ihrer
arbeit ganz wesentlich unterstützen nun
können sie zeigen und anwenden was sie
gelernt haben und sie können ihre
führungsstärke beweisen
ich wünsche ihnen dabei alles alles gute
viel erfolg und viel soldatenglück es
lebe das österreichische bundesheer es
lebe die republik österreich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich ersuche sie nun sich für die europa
hymne von ihren plätzen zu erheben
[Musik]
ja ich glaube man muss das ganze gerade
geschätzte gäste werde damen und herren
ich bitte sie wieder platz zu nehmen
oberst paul horn schmid der kommandant
der ausgerückten truppe mit dem
anschluss der frau bundesministerin
melden und um weitere befehle bitten
davor erlaube ich mir noch einige
wesentliche informationen zum weiteren
ablauf des festakts zu geben
sie erklärte er und festgäste leider ist
es uns bei dieser ausmusterung nicht
möglich unsere gastfreundschaft mit dem
traditionellen empfang zu unterstreichen
bedauernswerter weise lassen die
kopierschutzmaßnahmen ein geselliges
beisammensein nicht zu wir bitten um ihr
verständnis und freuen uns schon jetzt
darauf dieses bei einer der nächsten
veranstaltungen nachholen zu können
alle anwesenden kommandanten der großen
verbände der militärkommanden der
akademien und schulen sowie aller
nachgeordneten verbände haben die
möglichkeit in der kaserne sie
geschätzte absolventinnen und
absolventen zu treffen
die treffpunkte für die angehörigen der
dritten vierten und sechsten brigade
befinden sich bei der sporthalle für die
siebte brigade und angehörige der
luftunterstützung beim objekt zwei dem
unterkunftsgebäude die treffpunkte für
die angehörigen der akademien und
schulen beim berner das denkmal
die streitkräftebasis unweit der st
marien kapelle die angehörigen der durch
die streitkräfte unmittelbar geführten
geführten truppen und der
luftraumüberwachung biete sich im
innenhof des objekt 1 hauptgebäude ein
die angehörigen der militärkommanden
beim kreuz bauobjekt 6 die jeweiligen
treffpunkte sind ausgeschildert
geschätzte damen und herren werden
zuseherinnen und zuseher bei der
live-übertragung ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für ihre aufmerksamkeit und ihr
interesse an unserem festakt auf
wiedersehen an der heeres- und offiziers
akademie
das ganze hab ja ich hab schon
ja ich hoffe man die saison erhielten
weitere befehle das ganze recht
frau bundesminister obersten mit
billigung des systems zur ausmusterung
bittet um weitere befehle
vielen dank für den zu würdigen festakt
ab ersten april das ganze habt acht
ehrenkompanie kompanie
das ganze war das ganze oft
ja ich glaube schon
kompanie
zum ausmaß des herstellers unterbietet
das fernseh recht
[Musik]
ja ich hoffe schon dass erich hofmann
aus marschieren
[Musik]